monsieur le ministre depuis le mois de
juin semaine après semaine les députés
les républicains vous alertent sur les
factures insoutenables d'électricité de
nos entreprises qui risquent de les
condamner purement et simplement et avec
elle des milliers d'emplois dans notre
pays depuis le mois de juin nous vous
disons que vous faites fausse route en
comptant sur une solution européenne
pour régler notre problème depuis le 2
novembre nous en avons désormais
malheureusement la confirmation
l'Allemagne a annoncé unilatéralement
son dispositif grâce auxquels ces
entreprises verront leur facture
plafonnée à 130 euros le mégawattheure
pour 70% de leur consommation quand les
entreprises françaises au terme d'un
calcul alambiqué ne toucheront que
quelques dizaines d'euros pour
subventionner un prix de marché toujours
aussi élevé exemple concret une
entreprise de masse circonscription
closer c'est vue proposer un contrat à
environ 800 euros le mégawater avec
l'aide elle continuera donc à payer
682 euros le mégawattheure soit 8 fois
plus que ce qu'elle paye actuellement là
où une entreprise allemande dans les
mêmes conditions de marché paiera 330
euros on passe du simple eau double si
vous aviez obtenu une dérogation comme
les Espagnols et les Portugais en
subventionnant le prix du gaz destiné à
la production d'électricité mesure qui
nous aurait coûté 5 milliards donc
beaucoup moins coûteuses vous seriez en
mesure de proposer à nos entreprises un
prix moyen de marcher en France beaucoup
plus cohérent avec nos coûts réels de
production entre 50 et 70 euros le
mégawattheure monsieur le ministre quand
allez-vous enfin reconnaître que la
solution que vous avez choisie n'est de
tout évidence absolument pas à la
hauteur pour nos entreprises et
rectifier le tir il y a
urgence on va dans le mur il en va de la
sauvegarde de milliers d'emplois dans
notre pays
[Applaudissements]